so so let me ask you i asked you a
question about
de palma being a earner you said he's an
earner was he also a capable guy was he
also a guy that
was capable of you know crossing the
line and you know
handling the highest level of job if
needed well
the way it was explained to me when i
was proposed by greg de palma
how it works is they really the mob
looks for earners
guys are going to make money now if you
are a person
who plays by the rules keeps their mouth
shut
is capable of violence could do time
okay you get proposed to be put into
this
life but not everybody is a killer they
have their own shooters
how they work is you could be called
upon to do something whether it's dig a
grave
drive a getaway car do a blocked car
with the police
sometime and someplace they may call you
but unlike what the glamorization of
hollywood
not everybody's a killer not everybody
had to kill somebody to get straightened
out
okay there are a lot of guys who don't
because these guys who are making big
time money
which with the mobs about yes they do
have their shooters but not that
so keeping as far as greg is concerned
he never opened up to me about any
murders
simply because in his teaching of me of
mob ways
he says once that bullet leaves the gun
you never talk about it
so it's like why would he talk about
that unless he's that dumb to say if he
was involved
but what we do know about greg de palma
he was in nino gage's crew
it was the same crew of roy the male so
yes could he have been involved in
something you know roy demaio was just a
sadistic killer
so who knows what he did but as far as
with me
he never led me on to believe that he
was involved
nor did he brag that he was involved in
any killings
yeah only reason i'm asking is because
when i was sitting down with sammy
uh uh uh you know an interview with john
eli john eli said
ask anybody i've never seen john gotti's
senior kill anybody
john always had people like me kill
people right now that's john a light
saying
then i went and brought that up to sammy
sammy said
let me put it to you this way gotti if
he had to i don't know if he did or not
because you know sammy's such a true
mafioso he's not gonna
even if he knows the answer he wouldn't
say because it's not his style to do
that because he
still fully uh uh respects the code what
it was obviously minus what happened
years ago he said don't get it twisted
john gotti is very
very capable because if he needed to do
something he would do it he's not
somebody that you want to think that he
wouldn't do it
and then you hear john gotti junior when
they asked him about sammy even though
there's obviously a big following out
between those families years ago even
john gotti said
sammy the bull if there's one thing
about sam you have to respect he's a
true mafioso
everyone knew he was capable so that's
what i'm asking is the part was the palm
of somebody that was a capable person
that he could have done something
you know or was he just the guy that was
making money from what i know he was a
money maker
okay you know he was strictly the money
maker he had the west chester premier
theater
but he also had access to shooters
just like what you mentioned why get
your hands dirty when you can get
somebody to do
that for you makes sense makes sense
with uh
with that part by the way do you notice
a commonality amongst those who are
earners that had a very very high level
of
charm charisma persuasion sales
negotiation and and at the same time the
model was have
people around you that everyone feared
but you stayed the good guy so was
trying to stay the good guy
you know versus you had the bad cops
around you know the whole good cop bad
cop obviously this is uh
they're definitely far from being caps
but did you notice the main earners were
always protected and the best of the
best at
charming charismatic and attractive and
persuaders
oh absolutely spot on with that these
guys were
more polished like in the in the mob
there's your gangsters
and they're your racketeers racketeer is
a polished guy
if you are an individual who makes a lot
of money
you do surround look you're only allowed
to exist
because they let you exist and they
guard you
to exist so obviously you're going to
have the muscle
around you and you could also call on
that muscle
because if you're working with the mob
by all means
that they're going to say there's a
problem he's not going to get his hands
dirty
he'll go see a skipper or his soldier
and say look we got an issue here
they'll handle that for him
[Music]
you